on this week's afterwords program we
hear from former State Department
official Mary Thompson Jones on some
leaked diplomatic cables she's
interviewed by Paula de Brienne ski
former undersecretary for democracy and
global affairs
marry you've written a really terrific
book and on the back Joan I says Mary
Thompson Jones has used the trove of
WikiLeaks cables to provide a
fascinating account of how diplomacy
really works from the bottom up why did
you write this book
well undersecretary dobri annsofi thank
you very much for the compliment and for
the question I've admired your career
for a long time and in part admiration
was one motive I know firsthand what my
colleagues do and the WikiLeaks release
which was obviously not intentional on
the part of the government and something
that nobody had imagined gave us a
unique opportunity to see what diplomats
do in real time the cables deal with
world leaders many of whom are still
leading and still in place and it was an
opportunity for someone who had actually
been a diplomat and had the lived
experience of serving in some of the
countries in which these cables were
written to comment on them and try to
make sense of meaning of them for the
public at large
now how long was your career in the
Foreign Service and why did you want to
become a foreign service officer let's
start with that
I was hired in 1989 by the United States
Information Agency so I come from the
public diplomacy line of work I had 10
years in USIA and then as you know the
agency was folded into the US State
Department and I continued my career as
a public diplomacy officer in the State
Department and evolved into what
ultimately became the deputy chief of
mission for the US Embassy in Prague
which was my last assignment in the
Foreign Service
I left a Foreign Service in 2012 but why
did you want to be a foreign service
officer I have to ask you that because
I've been teaching a class and of my
class at Georgetown University many are
going into the Foreign Service and it's
interesting to me the students today
whom want to go into the Foreign Service
they want to be abroad they want to make
a difference what motivated you the same
things I think that motivated a lot of
my colleagues of course a sense of
patriotism with a small p a desire to
serve
my country but also a desire to learn
about the rest of the world to
experience foreign cultures foreign
languages I love languages and really
take a deep dive into how others think
about the United States I was really
caught by the mandate of mutual
understanding and the idea that we
should go abroad to serve American
foreign policy but also to bring back
home the opinions and viewpoints of
foreign publics that we're living and
working among and try to use that to
inform u.s. foreign policy explain if
you will a little bit about public
diplomacy I want to ask you that up
front because it's interesting when the
organization the United States
Information Agency was melded into the
State Department there was in fact a
really heavy debate and really very
controversial debate over the question
should it be brought in to the State
Department and there were some people
who said absolutely not because it
should be independent it would have a
greater impact abroad if it was on the
other hand then there was the issue of
well it should be in the State
Department because by bringing it in
it's melded into the policy process what
did you think about that before we turn
to the book the shorthand for public
diplomacy is to describe it as press and
culture and a lot of us who've worked in
it either sort of gravitate toward media
work which now includes social media but
writing speeches for ambassadors
arranging media interviews press
conferences cultivating contacts among
the journalistic community of whatever
country were posted to reading and
monitoring media all the time and the
cultural aspect which means bringing the
best of American culture to the rest of
the world which is a challenge because
we have pop culture and everyone thinks
they know a lot about America and what
they know is not often what is the best
of America and so it's an opportunity
for us to deepen foreign public's
understanding of what American culture
is all about and one of the best ways to
do this of course is to learn more about
the foreign
cultures in which we operate I love that
meshing of the two in the mutual
understanding that takes place when all
goes as it should and when we have an
opportunity to to deepen the layers of
knowledge we have about each other well
you're right certainly it plays a really
crucial role in understanding other
societies and it also plays a role which
isn't and hasn't been the traditional
role of the State Department and what
the State Department has focused on and
so I think the complementarity is a
crucial one indeed to go back to your
earlier question I think one of the
things that sets American public
diplomacy apart from what is practiced
in other countries is the imperative to
reach over or across heads of state and
governments directly to foreign publics
and by foreign publics it's a term of
art I really mean people people from all
walks of life not just journalists but
artists people who work in NGOs academia
people who are opinion leaders but
increasingly people from non-traditional
lines of work who may never achieve
notoriety in the halls of power but are
influential in their own communities and
in their own right and to be effective
diplomats not only public diplomacy
practitioners but diplomats of any sort
I think it's imperative not only to do
the traditional kinds of diplomacy which
the State Department has done since the
beginning of our country's founding but
also to explore the boundaries of public
diplomacy push the boundaries a bit and
cultivate foreign audiences and foreign
publics as well as the traditional
contacts which is the bread and butter
of traditional diplomacy
you know let's turn to your book you
laid out very well in these nine
chapters the WikiLeaks cables and you
did it very methodically and what I
think was very interesting about it was
the fact that which I don't think many
people realize the scale and the scope
of what was covered because what was
highlighted in
was mostly the classified portion and
the classified portion was really in the
scheme of things that only comprised a
small part as you point out in the book
there were a number of confidential but
also a surprisingly large number of
unclassified cables let me first start
with this what where were you on
November 28 2010 I was a diplomat in
residence working in New England I was
based at Tufts University at the
Fletcher School of Law and Diplomacy and
my job was to talk to aspiring diplomats
not only from Tufts but from across New
England about what it's like to be a
diplomat the kinds of policy issues
diplomats do with deal with how to
become a foreign service officer which
is not a very straightforward process as
I'm sure you know and what diplomacy
means in modern times students always
read George Kennan and everyone aspires
to write that telegram probably that's
had its moment in history and it's the
way foreign policy is made it's not
likely to happen again so explaining to
students well what is foreign policy and
where does the Foreign Service vidiian
where does the State Department fit in
who are the stakeholders in foreign
policy and what's the ad Brad is behind
it and what can you expect if you were
to go to a consulate or embassy anywhere
in the world what would that look like
what would it feel like so that was what
I was doing at the time what was your
initial reaction on that day and when
you learned of the WikiLeaks cables and
the fact that they were released and
what did you think their impact was
shock or disbelief like all of my
colleagues and sort of racking my brain
for what have we written in my previous
embassy which was obviously the one that
was at the top in my mind that might
embarrass us or might undermine US
foreign policy what had I cleared on
that I shouldn't have what might would
my name appear on and wishing that I
could sit down with my colleagues and
talk about it but no longer working at
the Embassy but now being based in New
England is the
diplomat in residence realizing that huh
I would love to be part of those
conversations but I have a different job
at the moment and my job is going to be
to answer questions from students and
faculty and the public who are
interested in the Foreign Service will
you say in the book that the release of
these cables wasn't unprecedented in a
certain way that there have been other
times historically where there have been
such releases of information but not in
the exact safe shape and form as in this
case talk a little bit about that and
putting this in context sure well well
leaks are part of the government as you
know from your long tenure in the
government it's part of journalistic
practice to cultivate sources to use
information Pentagon Papers of course
was one example of that dissent is also
an important aspect of this where I
think this is noteworthy is the role of
Julian Assange he was back in the news
recently because of his comments on the
unfortunate murder that took place here
in Washington DC just a couple of weeks
ago
Assange had an interesting angle he
unlike a journalist really disliked
government and was very suspicious and
was certain that there were underhanded
dealings and that somehow publishing
this in a sort of a radical transparency
would prove that all of us were up to no
good and in fact both the Guardian and
the New York Times who collaborated in
the initial release of these cables were
surprised to find that in fact you know
there were no underhanded dealings these
were mostly cables written by mid-level
officers going about their duties and
with some zest some zeal sometimes with
interesting approaches with a writing
style that was surprisingly readable and
not bureaucratic and earnestly making
efforts to understand the environments
in which they had been posted and
sending that information back to
Washington and I thought there was a lot
of eloquence in that that massage missed
because of his own agenda
so I part company with him in terms of
thinking that there there's a public
service being performed here and that
somehow you know there's there's dirt
that will come to light there's
surprisingly little dirt in all of this
it's it's interesting but it's not
nefarious it caught my attention that in
your book that you did mention the
Guardian and you also mentioned David
Sanger of the New York Times I even
wrote down the quote where he mentioned
that the cables were often eloquent and
occasionally entertaining it was very
interesting these reactions on the other
hand you had then Italian Foreign
Minister Franco Frattini who described
November 28th quote as the September 11
of world diplomacy was it the September
11 would you put it from what you've
just described it doesn't sound like you
thinking or view it as the same well we
survived the good news is but it's
interesting that it wasn't a one-off
Edwards Edward Snowden was waiting in
the wings
we had the DNC scandal just a month or
two ago I think leaks are going to be a
part of government life and the speed at
which and that the multiplicity of which
we communicate with each other now not
only in long cables Allah George Kennan
but short emails texts social media
tweets all of that is is going to be
part of the body politic understanding
how to classify it how to adjudicate it
how to know when something needs to be
secret and know when to share it is
something that I think is very much
under debate Hillary Clinton's emails
have reignited a lot of that debate and
the the volume at which we communicate
with each other now is just crushing the
way in which we classify and declassify
things cannot continue we have to find a
new method to do this a new way to
classify things you know with WikiLeaks
cables it's the officers who write the
cables
who decide what the classification
should be which means that you're
assuming that a person would know
sitting in Vientiane in Laos for example
whether or not something would be highly
damaging or just damaging or possibly
not damaging at all that Officer may not
have sufficient information in which to
make a judgment on that and there's the
long habit that the higher-level class
of a classification the more likely you
will have a readership that will be
intrigued and interested if you send an
unclassified cable well can't be
important right there was another aspect
that was addressed by people who reacted
at the time and that was was Trust
broken with foreign diplomats what was
the impact there and I I was struck you
quote then defense secretary Robert
Gates and he basically says I've heard
the impact of these releases on our
foreign policy described as a meltdown a
game-changer as a game changer and so on
I think those descriptions are fairly
significantly overwrought
the fact is governments deal with the
United States because it's in their
interest not because they like us not
because they trust us and not because
they believe we can keep secrets so a
question that just comes to my mind is
well was Trust broken because there are
others who reacted and felt that because
of the release the damage that was done
was there was trust broken in terms of
the confidentiality of the exchanges
that took place sure I I think there was
some damage
I think gates had a point of view that
was intentionally trying to calm people
and there was a level of hysteria
Asteria I don't think it was the 9/11 of
of world diplomacy either somewhere in
the middle one of the efforts that took
place before the New York Times
published was to sit down with State
Department officials dozens of them and
go through the cables and redact names
of sources that could be whose lives
could be in
world and this was something that I
understand the New York Times very
willingly engaged in and this was an
effort that took place over several days
before the release and the Guardian
honored the redactions that were made
WikiLeaks did not so their altum Utley a
lot of information and a lot of names
we're out there that arguably should not
have been yes I think coming from
journalism there's always a sense of
trust that if you assure a source that
what they're telling you is confidential
that you honor that trust and I think
people will be less open I don't think
this is uniquely an American problem
because we live in a global world and
keeping secrets is a lot harder and
having the means to guarantee someone
that their views will be kept
confidential is going to be harder in
future will that mean that people will
be less candid I don't know my sense of
human experience is that people often
want to talk they want to share their
views and they're willing to go to
enormous risks in order to get their
viewpoint across it's not just diplomats
that they talk to they post things on
Facebook in social media because they
want their opinions to be out there
we're in a time in which platforms for
communication are changing just
radically all the time and we can't we
can't guarantee confidentiality or
anonymity on the other hand people may
be more willing to take the risk and
just accept the fact that they it could
get out one of the reactions I took note
of and you cited in the book as a one
who was very revered in the Foreign
Service Tom Pickering ambassador Tom
Pickering and he had a wonderful quote
he said in archaeology you cover the
unknown in diplomacy you cover the known
you know you
a real silver lining that I think you
brought out wonderfully in this book and
that is that you basically say that the
leaked cables in a way did diplomats a
favor by also putting a spotlight in a
window not only on their work but also
as was cited by David Sanger the
eloquence of the writing the analysis
the assessments so there was also a very
much a silver lining to this occurrence
as well I I hope there was a silver
lining for the Foreign Service officers
you know this is really a story of
mid-level officers because they are
often the ones who do the actual writing
and the research that goes into making a
cable and there were so many great
stories of not only mid-level officers
but entry-level officers one that comes
to mind are a group of entry-level
officers in Suriname and Paramaribo
deciding to take a fact-finding mission
into the back part of the country going
in dugout canoes in the course of four
days to meet with a group of najuka
maroon who are the descendants of
escaped slaves in order to compile
information for an embassy Human Rights
report and on their way to do this they
discover all this illegal gold mining
operations that are happening that are
being run by Brazilians and by Chinese
and mercury is being dumped in the water
there's all kinds of prostitution and
all the things that go along with gold
mining operations the country didn't
have complete control of the back parts
of the region where this was happening
and the embassy officers ultimately did
meet the people that they had hoped to
meet with it was the first time in seven
years that anyone had met with them and
I I was charmed by so many aspects of
the story
the intrepid miss you know this is why
we joined the Foreign Service isn't it
to get out there leave the capital
behind and see parts of the world that
are not Kansas scene not California or
New York and they did it they didn't
need any special skills they weren't
senior high ranking people they they had
that sense of adventure and curiosity
and wanting to know a foreign people in
a
culture and then providing the context
for it that would make sense and answer
the so what question
back in Washington of you know well good
for you you did this but why should we
care well you should care because of
environmental reasons as well as human
rights reasons and here's what we
discovered that's that's real diplomacy
to me talk about the title of the book
and as we go through some of these
chapters but let's start with the title
and looking at leaked embassy cables in
America's foreign policy disconnect talk
about that disconnect what is the
disconnect that you came to hear I see
particularly in the time period that we
were looking at most of the WikiLeaks
cables deal with 2006 to 2010 and that's
that's an important data set it means
that we don't get into Benghazi which a
lot of people wonder about because
Benghazi happened 2012 2006 to 2008 was
the the nadir that the last two years of
the Bush administration then we have the
first two years in the euphoria of the
Obama administration so it's really an
interesting time in American diplomatic
history so that that's an important
guideline right there the disconnect it
seems to me is that the Bush
administration's view of the world was
informed greatly by 9/11 and how could
it not be this led in the aftermath too
many blue ribbon panels Commission's
boards of Inquiry all looking at
America's relations with Islam
with the Muslim world and what went
wrong and how could it be fixed there
were not a lot of American diplomats
who'd served in the Middle East not a
lot of scholars not a lot of people with
on-the-ground experience who were
informing that that those queries and
those those commissions and I think
that's a shame there was a lot of
writing taking place in these embassies
and consulates about what it's like to
be living in post 9/11 in an Arab
country or in the Muslim world and I'm
not sure that those cables were being
read and I'm not sure those voices were
heard
there were embassies that were not part
of the Muslim world which we're dealing
with anti-americanism and in some cases
with anti-americanism which was much
worse than what was happening in the
Muslim where Argentina would be a case
in point where at some points the public
opinion ratings in terms of a popularity
of the United States according to Pew
Global Research were you know 12% what
happened in Argentina this is not a
Muslim nation this has nothing to do
with 9/11
where did things go so wrong the embassy
had a lot of answers a lot of ideas a
lot of initiatives but I'm not sure that
they they got a hearing that's one of
the recommendations that you also have
at the end of the book is looking at the
connectivity between the policymakers in
Washington and those in the field and
making sure that the voice in the field
is well heard isn't that one of the
strains through the various chapters and
that you do come out with the
recommendation one of your
recommendations or appeals at the end
yes I am certainly not so idealistic as
to believe that you know Washington is
waiting to hear from mid-level career
diplomats out in Asuncion or Paraguay or
wherever they're not the foreign
policymaking establishment is as complex
as it has ever been
ah you you are part of that you you've
lived that experience you know that we
have stakeholders from single-issue
groups from everybody from the PTA on
down Congress is ever more interested in
foreign policy the number of agencies
that look globally is increased the
State Department yes but one of many so
yes it's it's not likely that foreign
service officers are ever going to
direct foreign policy but what I
discovered in reading the cables in it's
my own view is that there it follows a
tradition which I think is unique to
American diplomacy in which sometimes
policymakers almost look with suspicion
on American officers and even though we
are
American and uphold all the same values
and are sworn to defend and protect the
US Constitution just as they are when
we're sent overseas we are seen as
people with client Titus
people who've gone over to the other
side people who've lost their their
sense of what it means to support and
defend American policy I think this
comes from the McCarthy era other eras
Vietnam era and I think it's unique in
the United States that that we have this
dichotomy that somehow you you spend too
much time overseas and the more you know
about a foreign culture the less you
know about your own and I don't think it
should be that way I think what we have
to offer is important and certainly
trustworthy and we need a voice in in
George Kennan State it was harder to
have that voice because transportation
was more difficult communications are
more difficult now you know you could
have secured video conferences it's very
easy to bring people to the table
virtually or electronically or on a
plane and that expertise is being lost
and to me that that's what the cable
showed and it's not a partisan issue I
think it happens in Republican as well
as in Democratic administrations
there was no watershed moment when the
Obama administration came into office
that suddenly it was clear that cables
were being read whereas before they
hadn't quite the contrary they it was
kind of business as usual I think you
raise an important point and that is
that there's a balance that's needed
every administration that comes in is
going to have its mission it's going to
have its agenda but also what you really
underscore and bring out is the range in
the diversity and the experience and
analysis of those in the field that have
something substantial to contribute to
the decision making process and it may
not necessarily as you're pointing out
mean that it will necessarily be the end
result but hey it's important to make
sure that those considerations are
factored in into
operations and not ignored and by
whichever administration in this case
and that's something you really tried to
bring out here let me ask you about
public diplomacy because you yourself
were a public diplomacy officers you
describe and you know here interestingly
enough in the cables that were leaked
there's also an interesting aspect
that's brought out in the public
disciplines the area and you mentioned
it in fact moments ago in the example
that you gave I believe in Suriname in
this cultural diplomacy and what
actually can come out whether it's
historical weather it's about the roots
of a society talk a bit about that and
how public diplomacy factors into the
cables that were leaked well the Iraq
chapter I think is informative in that
regard because there was a lot of
controversy at the time about what could
be accomplished in a country that was as
war-torn as Iraq was and sadly still is
and the Bush administration made a point
to make Iraq the the new embassy in Iraq
the largest embassy in the world however
with single year staffing requirements
the number of foreign service officers
available and those who could speak
Arabic and could be effective was very
small and soon turnover began to be a
problem and it became very hard to fill
positions Foreign Service officers
wondered well isn't it also important to
work in Haiti or I've spent four years
learning Mandarin shouldn't I be working
in China or you know fill in the blanks
the administration very emphatically
said no it's most important it is our
priority that we fully staff the embassy
in Baghdad and there was a lot of
discussion some of it became very public
as I mentioned in the chapter and yet
the the evidence from the cables
suggests that officers went willingly
whole heartedly energetically and
enthusiastically and accomplished some
impressive things while they were there
even without knowledge of Arabic even
without an in-depth knowledge of the
region but
using the tools they had been given
improvising being creative and getting
out and trying to relate to people and I
think it's one of public diplomacy is
real unheralded success stories and I
understand that it's hard to talk about
the use of the word success in Iraq in
the same sentence because things are
still so very much up in the air but the
cables suggest a trajectory of officers
who answered the call were loyal did as
the administration asked served and
accomplished impressive things well you
mention
go Leah Mary who was the Assistant
Secretary of State for educational
cultural affairs at the time and then
you also mention ambassador Adam airily
fluent in Arabic and who came on the
scene in Iraq and how he really got
things going in a wide variety of areas
the Fulbright scholarships yes the
Sister Cities program educational
exchanges and you cite the fact that in
that timeframe actually and as covered
by these leaks that it really shows this
scale of this activity that was achieved
and also under challenging circumstances
not only challenging circumstances there
in Iraq but also as you're pointing out
just the rules of the Foreign Service
itself and it was very striking his mark
on that period of Iraq well we doubled
the Fulbright Program it became the
largest in the world I think we had 70
grantees at one point we had other
programs as well the English language
teaching program the Fellows Program and
we did cultural programming my
colleagues put on theatrical
performances and had standing-room-only
crowds coming because Iraqis were hungry
for normal life for cultural events and
programs that were offered in their own
language that they could relax and enjoy
and that's an important part of
diplomacy too it's not going to win
hearts and minds necessarily and it's
not policy based but it's definitely
about human outreach and cultivating
contacts
and opening up the space in which more
difficult dialogues could also take
place once you establish contact and you
make human connections which is one of
the foundational rationales for public
diplomacy I believe you have a wonderful
quote in here you have many of them
a wonderful one of us is director at the
time of the Bay of Pigs of 1961 Edward
Murrow saying quote dammit if they want
me in on the crash landings I better
damn well be in on the takeoffs unquote
the question that arises there and one
of the criticisms that does arise is
they're only good coming in is there a
hesitancy from the field of only having
cables that will tell you things that
you want to hear what about the crash
landings what about those the bad news
about being factored in talk about that
yeah it's hard to write a cable
describing a failure it takes a lot of
guts first of all it has to get cleared
by the Ambassador who may or may not
want to acknowledge that a failure has
taken place under his or her watch
nobody wants the bad news but bad news
happens a good example of that was Karen
Hughes's visit Karen Hughes was very
activist undersecretary but she was not
always liked by the field and her visits
sometimes hit sour notes her penchant
for introducing herself as a mom as a
Christian to describe the post 9/11 u.s.
foreign policy in almost messianic terms
was off-putting to multicultural
audiences particularly non-christian
audiences she tried hard to reach out to
women and women in Turkey Indonesia
Saudi Arabia places like that were
culturally very different and I think
she did not succeed and I think the
embassy was very circumspect and how it
went about reporting that now in their
defense whenever you have a delegate
coming and visiting the delegation has
the right to clear on the cable so
anything you write either ambassador
Hughes or somebody on her staff would
have to clear you can see that they had
some workarounds they described not the
meetings with the public but meetings
she had with ministers these are pro
forma you know nothing ever goes wrong
in a meeting with the minister it's very
rare but that to happen or in one case
she delivered a lot of English language
textbooks wasn't that nice that that
says so much because it's not saying the
more important parts which are the
policy parts or embassies will resort to
reporting on local media reports of an
event so the fact that in Turkey Hughes
had some rocky meetings the embassy
wasn't able to describe those but the
local media did and the embassy then
quoted the local media talking about it
so that was sort of a workaround for
them well I know those things are always
very very challenging
I know ambassador Hughes and I know her
intent of course was a noble one to try
to in a down-to-earth way impact
audiences and I think it was a tough
period when she took that on you have a
section on crises let's talk a little
bit about that because you have three
very different crises you talk about the
earthquake in Haiti as reported in these
cables the cyclone and Burma and then
the coup in Honduras talk about crisis
diplomacy what are the challenges here
and what did these leaked cables do or
not do in this regard I think they shed
a wonderful light on why tax payers
ought to support embassies overseas any
CNN crew can go to Haiti and take
footage of the collapsed government
ministries in the presidential palace
photos are shocking they tell the story
same with cyclone nargis in Burma same
idea but you need context subtext
background first-person accounts and a
lot of these were sitreps or situational
reports written hour after hours
things unfolded and they were
unclassified because there was no means
in which to send out classified
information because communications were
very difficult this is often true in a
crisis that's a natural crisis an
earthquake or a cyclone or a flood the
tsunami would be another example of that
embassy officers are innovative they're
creative they're dedicated they don't go
home at 5 o'clock they are intent on
organizing they understand the
bureaucracy of the US government and how
assistance can be put in place they need
to connect with the local people such
local people as are available and get
acquiescence in this and let's sort of
get an order of precedence so that you
don't bring in things ahead of other
things and the Haiti cables were just a
remarkable blueprint for how do you
stand up a team in the face of a just
absolutely overwhelming disaster we lost
a foreign service officer in Haiti Tory
DeLong and we lost many Foreign Service
Nationals at the same time and of course
hundreds of thousands of Haitians lost
their lives - but how do you what do you
do first well here's the answer here's
what the embassy did first was it right
could they have done better but you know
it's debatable but it's a case study and
it it's logical they they dealt with
what they had they dealt with the people
they could reach they reached back to
the US government and little by little
they put Haiti back on its feet one of
the most vulnerable countries in the
Western Hemisphere country that arguably
never quite gets back on its feet but
nonetheless they they put a plan into
place remarkably early in the process
and you can see as the cables get more
routine and more detailed less anecdotal
you're no longer dealing with you know
bodies rotting in the street but you're
dealing with systemic issues that are
you know they're starting up the garment
factories again they've got the ports
berating airports functioning it's
taking less time to go Overland they're
bringing in supplies and it's kind of a
testimony to American can-do ISM but I
really enjoyed writing the the Haiti
crisis because of the optimistic can-do
aspect of it the one on Burma had a real
impact because you also pointed out how
the cables and what was written provided
a kind of blueprint for an open door for
what unfolded later in the context of
Burma because we had a closed-door
policy at that time sanctions on Burma
and this was a question about providing
aid and also getting in and bringing in
aid and you well articulate how
ironically these leaked cables point out
the kind of foundation that was laid for
later and opening into Burma yeah
mistakes were really much higher because
there was no question in Haiti that we
had a very open and historical
long-standing relationship as you point
out we did not have that in Burma what
was so remarkable about cyclone nargis
and that the embassy chronicled so well
was the generals utter lack of contact
with their people they had moved the
capital away from rangoon
they were seemingly actually unaware of
the extent of devastation and damage and
very ignorant about what a host
wholesale humanitarian operation entails
they assumed that they would have clear
a few international flights they'd bring
in pallets of water and supplies MREs
and that would be it
they didn't understand that disaster
relief requires assessment people
working on the ground all of this is
anathema if you're running a very
authoritarian very tight regime because
this breaks down barriers and people
suddenly need to rely on NGOs that you
to rely on community structures and
understand what the needs are and you
have foreigners walking around on the
ground talking to your people as the
embassy predicted this exposed the
fissures in the
generals control and ultimately had a
huge impact in the generals fall from
power and the rise of ansan tsuki which
you know has been a a great development
for US relations with Burma Honduras you
juxtapose all of these in Honduras is a
very different situation over the
question of a coup yes I hear say a bit
about that well this is our own backyard
which makes it much less exotic than the
Burma or Myanmar this is a country we
know well Congress knows this country
well it's also a country with the
troubled past and a history of American
intervention is just - in a lot of the
Central American countries right next
door we have Daniel Ortega the
Sandinistas the return of Daniel Ortega
and not too far away Venezuela Hugo
Chavez in a sense that the hemisphere is
shifting and becoming much more leftist
and much more anti-american President
Zelaya
was unceremoniously deposed and
illegally deposed I think there can be
no question about it but over a very
ambiguous legal maneuver in which he was
trying clearly to obtain a second term
in office which was not in line with the
Honduran Constitution at the time some
Americans particularly those who were
afraid of the trend of Chavez and others
and the sort of domino effect thought
the coup was probably a good thing in
disguise because it allowed for a more
conservative administration to come in
and it cut off what was clearly going to
be an unconstitutional attempt at a
second term in office others including
the administration President Obama and
Secretary Clinton decried it as
unconstitutional and an affront to
democracy they consciously kept our
ambassador in place to deal with the
government the de facto government
at the time and try to work within the
boundaries of the Honduran system to
reestablish the rule of law it's
fascinating because the European Union
pulled all of its ambassadors most of
the OAS also pulled all of its
ambassadors so our American master was
one of the few who remained throughout
the intensity of reporting was almost of
the same level as the intensity of the
Haiti earthquake reporting hour by hour
what's happening day by day the
administration asked arias are our
colleague in Costa Rica to serve as a
mediator in this process he becomes part
of the reporting efforts and what he
thinks and who's saying what to whom and
it's it's a fascinating interior look at
a coup not in the first 24 hours but in
what it means over the long term and how
do you put the toothpaste back in the
tube how do you get this country back on
democratic track after such a long and
it was a very prolonged coup and
aftermath I know very well ambassador
who go Lorenz he's a good friend and he
had a really a challenge before him he's
a very very fine foreign service officer
you had a section on travel one of the
chapters which is very surprising in a
way and it's surprising but yet not
because anyone who knows the Foreign
Service knows that the most interesting
cables at times are the ones when
they're out of capital and you gave the
example of Suriname but give another
example of of a cable that really sheds
light on we're getting out of the
capital and actually getting in into the
country can make a difference and have a
real impact on policy well Central Asia
is one of my favorite areas of reporting
for this because someone discovered that
truck stops are a great place to get
information and this region has many
denied areas for American diplomats
particularly Iran Turkmenistan is a
border country and the embassy realized
at some point that they could sort of
set up shop at a Turkmen truck station
and chat up the drivers at the cafe's on
their way in and the way out and it
became something of a listening post it
was fascinating
I loved the again the intrepid nosov it
the ingenuity of it as a workaround and
the fact that people got out of their
desks out of the embassy out of the
building and did what I think we're all
paid to do which is go talk to the
people find out what's going on you
can't just sit reading the newspaper and
writing your reports from the newspaper
you have to actually talk to two real
people and the the dramas the little
vignettes the stories that they found
were fascinating the they found an
Iranian GarageBand which later became
the yellow dogs which achieved some
degree of fame in the United States and
then tragically the many of the
musicians in the band were killed by a
fellow Iranian over a dispute that was
not political but talking to two rock
guitarists - video gamers these are
young people in Iran and these are
people that we will be dealing with more
and more in future and we need to know
them what they think their worldview
what's important to them and I was so
pleased to see that this was happening
there's another side to that story and
that is when Foreign Service officers
get out of capital and their security is
in jeopardy
and one must always be reminded that
there are good stories but there are
also stories that are told because
they're willing to put their lives on
the line and to get out and about and
they don't know what will happen next
and I think that interestingly enough
number of these cables also point to
that fact as well as you articulate in
the book let me go to this section on
frenemies friends and enemies the phases
of diplomacy one of the issues that you
try to tackle and I wonder what your
answer is is when American values and
American interests come into conflict
how do you grapple with that how does
one grapple with that and I think
there's a spotlight on that
respect of foreign policy here sure
obviously a lot has been written about
the Mubarak the Lugo Chavez is the the
the notorious people who captured the
headlines and the question of well do
you continue to deal with the country do
you stop dealing with the country how do
you deal with the country when you don't
like the regime and it's a perennial
question in foreign policy your your
viewer dealt with this on a daily basis
of course Hillary Clinton's written a
lot about this too and of how to choose
hopefully we can opt for democracy we
can opt for individual freedom but we
don't always win Robert Mugabe is a
great example power today in Zimbabwe
the embassy wrote just constantly and
relentlessly on his undemocratic streak
on his human rights violations how he
ran the country into ruin economically
country that had been one of the bread
baskets of Africa one of the more
functional democracy is in Africa it one
point and how land reform gone wrong
just toured the country apart obviously
we don't deal with Mugabe we but we want
to have a presence in the country we we
want to continue to talk to gutsy people
who are going to attempt to challenge
the regime we have a mixed track record
of encouraging people Hungary it would
be a case in point going back quite a
ways but other times too where we have
to be careful we we don't want to
promise what we can't deliver we want to
stand for what we believe as Americans
but we can't be so naive as to simply
turn our backs on reality and do this do
personalities drunk politics no but they
had foreign politics and clearly the the
friend of frenemies chapter was a lot of
fun to write because there are a lot of
people waiting in the wings that most
Americans have never heard of and there
some interesting characters out there
and they come to power through
circuitous and interesting means so that
when you see a Hugo Chavez he didn't
come from nowhere the embassies probably
been reporting or had been reporting on
him for many decades before he
ultimately rose to power Daniel Ortega
is another one he's an old baby we know
this guy from way back nothing she
surprised us about Daniel Ortega anymore
yet officers come with fresh eyes we
rotate officers frequently so he's a new
experience his inauguration was
obviously a new experience for the
officers who compiled the cable
describing the antics and hijinks of of
that inauguration but the philosophical
question you posed this one that's just
absolutely essential to diplomacy it's
one that I wish would be debated more
right now in this electoral period
because it's important to get at the
nuances of that question American values
versus American practical realism and
their many schools have thought on it
and many thoughtful people have had
written on this at great length and
there are no easy answers but it
troubles me a bit that it's kind of been
swept to the side and it's not part of
what we're talking about these days when
we talk about foreign policy you seem to
also have great fun with the section
devoted to wild animals and jungle
diplomacy as you call it and it seems
you came to a conclusion that
interestingly enough with these leaked
cables that it also pointed out the
important roles of nongovernmental
organizations and foreign policy and
this was an area where they came into
play in bringing environmental concerns
to the forefront even despite some of
the resistance of certain governments
isn't that one of your core messages in
that chapter
well it's something that I don't think
is well understood yet I was astounded
at the number of cables on animals the
way WikiLeaks is set up you can just
write in you know rhinos and click and
you know outcomes hundreds of cables on
rhinos
yes I'm passionate too about wildlife
and rhinos
and it was interesting how the embassy
chose to write about these because it
isn't trivial it's it's very important
but there are international wildlife and
conservatory organizations that have
amazing budgets an amazing personnel
staff that are you know the creme de la
creme in terms of people with all the
education and background to really deal
with these issues and when these
organizations choose to just set up shop
and turn their backs on the government
or are just frustrated with governments
that don't seem to share their
Commission in their commitment and they
have the resources at their disposal to
to operate without government consent it
should give us pause nobody elected
World Wildlife Fund they do good work
The Nature Conservancy same thing Nature
Conservancy's assets outstrip the assets
of many African countries in terms of
their land and their holdings who do
they answer to and are all their
decisions in the interest of the country
itself this this is perhaps a scope for
another book or another writer and
another person who's interested in this
but I was interested that this new
generation of diplomats certainly is
passionate about wildlife and the
environment and getting out of embassies
and seeing the reality on the ground
that certainly came out it really jumped
out to other chapters you had you had a
chapter devoted to corruption and the
issue of procurement elections and then
you also had a chapter devoted to
Secretary Clinton during her tenure and
then your conclusions at the end
let me just on those two remaining
chapters ask you in terms of corruption
I would say that definitively there's a
real service that these cables have
performed and have made certainly in
terms of tracking elections shed some
light on that I know myself of having
been an election observer how crucial it
is
to have that information before
observing an election for example I
loved the embassy cables on Elections
because they they describe the
atmospherics behind it as well as the
technical operations of it you know what
constitutes free and fair how do we
measure it what's the yardstick for that
and how do we assess the outcome
embassies don't write just on the day of
the election there's usually several
months of reporting that goes along in
advance because candidates need space in
democracy to operate they need to be
able to advertise they need to have
equal access to media these things are
not a foregone conclusion in a lot of
places in the world but the flavor that
they added and the anecdotes they
described as well when things would go
wrong how local election officials would
work to solve them was interesting and
spoke to human resource fulness and the
reality of elections in places where you
can't count on reliable electricity or
elections taking place in Ukraine in the
middle of winter and people you know
coming on horse-drawn sleighs and things
which is sort of picturesque but what
what do you do when you see one family
member voting for 30 members of his clan
as it happens in Uzbekistan for example
and is considered perfectly normal
because he's here - on behalf of his
clan one man one vote one man one clan
it's a different view and you know the
OSCE doesn't even bother if the
standards are just so different so how
how can you close this gap how can you
suggest ways forward for a country
that's clearly in transition and clearly
has a long way to go
and what meaning do you make from an
election so that when a member of
Congress simply says well was it free
and fair yes or no that doesn't really
get at it you need a lot more context in
order to understand what's happening
iíve seen elections more in Latin
America then in but also in the Czech
Republic and yeah there are a lot of
interesting
differences about all that and it's one
of the more interesting tasks of embassy
officers and people from Washington who
often join us and go out to these
polling places to see how it transpires
on the ground before we conclude I want
to focus on two questions and one
related to the last chapter on Hillary
Clinton and also something that you cite
relevant to Condoleezza Rice and that's
this concept of transform and
transformational diplomacy define what
it is for our viewers and also where is
it now it was something that was
announced by Secretary Rice and the
during secretary Clinton's a term at the
State Department where is it now where
do you see it going what is it and where
is it going I think that was one of
secretary Rice's most fundamental
contributions her two speeches at
Georgetown but the first one in
particular and she cast this in terms
everyone could understand she said look
we have as many American embassy
officers in Germany as we have in India
a country of more than a billion people
how can that be that's hard to argue
with and she began a redeployment that
changed because of Iraq and suddenly
those officers weren't going to India or
to Haiti or any of their they certainly
were going to Germany more but they were
being diverted to Iraq but that idea
that we needed to rethink the globe and
leave the post-war era leave the
post-communist transformation era and
look at the world in a completely
different way was something that she
really keyed off and I think Secretary
Clinton continued along that track
foreign service officers now understand
that it's not likely that they're going
to get a lot of promotions going from
Paris to London to Rome if indeed they
would be allowed to do that which is
highly doubtful the exciting work and
where a lot of the cables come from are
from places that a lot of people have to
look up on the map to find and we're
going to spending more and more time
more energy more commitment and I think
more personnel in those places
because those are the cutting edge of
American foreign policy and American
interests let's conclude on this note
what were your three please I want you
to mention them you articulate it in the
book your three please
at the end your three recommendations
going forward well I I do believe that
the cables ought to be declassified
they're out there on the internet and
what's happened now is that
international students professors
students of diplomacy have access to
them American students if they aspire to
the Foreign Service may feel a little
bit less secure having any kind of
academic deep dive into them and I think
you know the the cats out of the bag
let's just go ahead I also think that we
need professional leadership in public
diplomacy many of the other branches of
the State Department have been
extraordinarily well served by officers
who have come up through the ranks
worked in the field for decades and then
assumed leadership syn undersecretary
roles we've had some excellent political
appointees as well unfortunately public
diplomacy is one cone in which the
turnover has been too rapid the depth of
expertise and the commitment of a lot of
the former under secretaries of public
diplomacy has left the field poorly
served I wish that at some point that
perhaps the next administration might
consider pulling someone from the ranks
of the public diplomacy specialists and
selecting someone in a leadership role
for that mary i want to say you've
written an excellent book i am gonna put
it up at this time it really is very
thoughtful thank you any student a
foreign policy and practitioner of
foreign policy it's not only informative
but it really is fascinating i learned a
number of things that even though i've
had 25 years in government that i
learned from this book and really just
thank you so much for your contribution
well thank you secretary it's been fun
chatting with you thank you
likewise